hello everybody welcome to NDC DevOps we
hope to be doing this in person but for
reasons I think you can probably
understand we've taken some different
decisions about how we're running the
event I'm actually would normally have
been with you in Oslo I was planning to
actually to do this from Oslo even
though you were going to be at home but
in the end to head home myself just in
case there's any interruptions with
flights so in advance I do want to
apologize if there's any odd audio or
two facts normally I go to a proper
rented studio for things like this but
wasn't able to get that working at short
notice I won't explain the kind of Rube
Goldberg esque setup I've got going on
here at home to make all of this work
but I'm hoping it all holds together
literally some of this setup is held
together with sticky tape but you know
we adapt and we survive today we're
going to be talking well I'm going to be
talking about the challenges of
navigating the world of private cloud
and maybe why the idea of you having
your own private cloud might not be the
best idea in the world we are going to
be taking questions as well so if you
want to go over to slide oh you can use
this code here so that's hashtag Y eight
six zero and that's going to allow you
to ask me questions of the system I've
got those questions up online and so I'm
planning to talk for about 40 minutes
and then have plenty of time afterwards
for Q&A with all of you and I'm very
happy to carry on that Q&A via Twitter
afterwards we're going to be having a
sort of virtual online conference today
that means we can't bump into people and
have conversations in the hallway track
things like that so it may well be that
I'll take that conversation if you ask
me things on to Twitter afterwards we're
just gonna see how this all works so
thank you once again for coming along
for those of you who don't know much
about me that's okay I'm not offended my
name's Sam human I run my own company we
do training advising consultancy
services I was actually just doing a
two-day training course on micro
services with some of the people who
came to the conference some of you might
build the Lyons place in which case
hello again we did that you know sort of
a hybrid way we had some people in the
room with me doing the class we had some
people as well as she at home sort of
works I think we're getting better at
many years ago I wrote a book called
building micro-services it was actually
released in 2015 and I've just had a new
book release called monolith to
microservices which is all about how you
take an existing monolithic architecture
and move that in an incremental fashion
over to a microservice architecture yeah
loads of patterns in there if you're if
you think micro-services might be right
for you there's lots of concrete pads to
help you make that happen
make sense but also there's a lot of
advice in there if you're not sure
whether or not microservice is the right
way forward I'm very much the opinion
that they're not right for everybody
there's a lot of content in there to
help you understand should I even be
doing this but that's not actually what
we're about going to talk about today
we're actually gonna be talking about
today is the cloud and the private cloud
and the public cloud and the private
cloud and you know all of these amazing
tools that we now have access to that
you made architectures like
microservices much easier to deal with
but there is this idea that everybody is
moving to the public cloud and that's
where everyone is but actually if you
look at the data that sort of trend
towards people rushing to use services
like azure an AWS has sort of stalled so
I keep an eye on the date of these
things because I don't have much else to
do it my life so I you know I don't have
to look at the data from a company with
IDC and they track the proportion of
spent across IT operations and they
break that down based on how much money
gets spent on traditional data center
stuff this is like you're buying your
servers and kind of old fashioned style
operations infrastructure then the spent
on private cloud which is increasingly
going on things like running open shift
clusters and things like that and then
the spent on public cloud and what's
been really interesting is a although
you see that sort of public clouds spend
increasing year-on-year it has actually
stalled if you look at the actual
proportion of spent which is kind of on
premise so that's see that's both your
private cloud and your traditional sort
of ops IT spend that still represents
70% of all IT spend on infrastructure is
actually on-premise spent so although
you might have this view that everyone's
on public cloud turns out that's not
case the other thing is that that has
the flat light you know if you look at
the numbers for that sort of 70 percent
mark more or less for 2018 was also sort
of flat into 2019 and so that this trend
towards public cloud actually seems to
be slowing which is kind of odd so we've
got this situation where the proportion
of IT spent on the public cloud is
increasing so you actually although it's
increasing slowly but the overall market
is actually growing so what I mean by
that is year-on-year we're spending more
money in total on infrastructure so the
total market is going up but the
proportion of public cloud is sort of
flat so it kind of actually means that
we're spending more money year on year
on private infrastructure so even if
there's a little bit of an erosion of
the proportion of that market we're
spending more money every single year so
actually people are buying more machines
people are running more machines on
premise so it's kind of a weird we think
to think about you see all this great
hype about you know as you an AWS and
Google cloud and any player early cloud
and all these other things but people
are still buying lots and lots and lots
of hardware and spending lots of private
data centers and that's kind of that's
been an interesting thing to me because
my own experiences as I've always
considered myself a junior ops person
and a semi senior developer in terms of
my experience set has always been the
quality of experience that I get as a
software development professional has
been much better on the public clouds
and it has been in what I think consider
on my private on you know in-house
infrastructure so I'm really interested
as to what's been going on what's what
happened why is it we had this stalling
effect why have we had maybe not as many
people moving to the public cloud as we
might expect now part of this might just
be that kind of some of you may have
seen this diffusion of innovation curve
right this is looking at how when a new
technology comes out you get these early
adopters that sort of rush into this and
it might just be the
so what the reason we're seeing this
stalling effect in terms of the adoption
of private public clouds is the fact
that well we're actually having all
those people that were able to move have
moved and we're now into this space
where we're dealing with the majority of
the market that you based on analysis
and other sectors just takes a while to
get up to speed with these things it's
almost like the people that can move
easily have already moved easily and the
people that haven't considered moving to
public cloud might have some real
structural issues around this this could
be maybe there are local constraints
maybe there are situations with their
industry I actually think there's also
potentially something else that we could
blame for the growth of public cloud
stalling somewhere and that might be
something like kubernetes cuz I have a
theory that the fact that we are the
people are building and running
kubernetes clusters is is sort of
helping us indulge in this of sunk cost
fallacy right too many of us are
indulging in this sort of sunk cost
fallacy that we can have of our own
private cloud and that that private
cloud is going to be fantastic and we've
been doing this for years
stopping and now we think our kubernetes
kubernetes will solve all of my problems
and IQ I - you can have a private cloud
experience that's just as good as if I
was running directly on Azure or
directly on AWS so why do we even talk
about cloud why is cloud really
important and so I'm hoping that some of
you may have read this report this is
the state of devil's report from 2019
this actually was originally created by
DevOps Research agency and they've been
looking at doing research into the
efficacy of various different software
development practices so going back
years so they research they survey
hundreds of companies thousands of
companies all around the world and they
look at the delivery practices the
software development practices
everything from what technology do you
use to branching strategies you use
systems architecture development
processes code reviews and they look at
how khat strongly correlated those
practices are to those teams which are
high-performing
teams so one of the things they found as
part of this research in the 2019
addition is republished which actually
also tallies with the things they found
in the 2018 report is that cloud is
still a huge differentiator for
high-performing teams so high and what
they called elite performing teams are
24 times more likely to be making use of
a cloud platform so in other words they
see a high and strong correlation
between those high-performing teams and
the use of cloud and for them a
high-performing team is a is teams with
the ability to ship software very
quickly with very low failure rates but
also they look at track other factors
for high-performing teams like morale
and sort of business effectiveness as
well so the report showed that the -
moving teams are 24 times more likely
than low performers and this is a next
bit that's kind of very specific to
execute on all 5 capabilities of cloud
computing and this is where things get a
bit interesting because of course you
might read this and say hang on this
this is all about public cloud private
cloud that's what this talks about and
you know I'm thinking I'm gonna just
give away the the end conclusion at the
beginning I think you're pretty much
better off with public cloud private
cloud in general um but there's nothing
here on the state of Devlin's report
that says you have to use a public cloud
or that yeah after use private cloud
they talk about cloud computing more
generally so they don't say you had to
use public cloud in this report so
coming back to what they said the
high-performing teams are 24 times more
likely than low performers to execute on
all 5 capabilities of cloud computing so
what are these 5 capabilities of cloud
computing because I think this is often
where people get a bit confused about
what cloud means now these five
capabilities of cloud computing are
basically defined by an organization
called NIST in the US and they sort of
come up with these five categories and
say if you've got a platform that gives
you these five capacities say these five
capabilities then
you have a cloud the very first thing
that we get is that were the first the
first of these five sort of concepts or
five capabilities of cloud is the fact
that you have on-demand
self-service okay so on-demand
self-service so what they go on to say
is a consumer that might be you as a
developer or an Operations person a
consumer can unilaterally provision
computing capabilities such as server
time network storage as needed
automatically without requiring human
interaction with each services provider
so basically here you if you need
something you go to the cloud and say I
want that thing and you get it without
having to check in with anybody else an
awful lot of private cloud
infrastructure that I've worked with
does not have this capability you have
to raise tickets still to get things
done you have to ask permission around
getting these things done what you want
this is the really important part of any
cloud experience is on-demand
self-service so think about your own
private cloud experiences if you're
running a private cloud at home I hope
that's a bad idea I actually kind of do
a little kubernetes cluster onto my
table but if you're in your office you
can you do this can you just spin up
machines when you need to without having
to check in with people or do you have
some kind of ticketing process in place
now to be fair this isn't a private
cloud issue necessarily but the public
cloud almost by definition is built to
embrace this in the idea and embody this
idea and to some extent this is the most
important idea that public cloud has
brought to us but even then you can
misuse the public cloud I was spending
some time with a price sort of a price
comparison company based in Europe and I
was chatting to their CIO the CIO says
yeah we're using AWS and it's working
out really well for us and I was
confused by this because I spoke to the
developers and the developers has been
say it would be great but we can use a
cloud provider and I'm sort of I said
well how does the CIO say we use in the
cloud and the developers say we're not
using the cloud it turns out that
everything they running work was
actually on AWS but the developers
didn't know that because to spin up a
machine on
AWS they literally had to raise a ticket
tender take it over to JIRA an
Operations person would see that ticket
they didn't go over to the AWS console
and click some buttons to give them a
machine so you this is just like a
complete facepalm moment right because
you've taken a platform that gives you
the ability to do self-service without
human interaction and you'd basically
hamstrung that whole platform by pasting
these layers and these barriers in the
face of it it's like you've gone to all
the effort to bring this into your
organization and then put more money and
effort into denying yourself the ability
to take advantage of this platform so it
was I had to be quite polite about the
whole thing but this is kind of crazy
right if you have to race write a ticket
to spin up a VM you don't have a cloud
platform you might have virtualization
but you don't have a cloud though
on-demand self-service is important
what's next
broad network access this one's a little
bit harder to understand but this
basically means you can access the
resource from a broad array of different
devices so you can access these cloud
access files by mobile devices and
different you know untethered devices
something like this this is sort of a
bit of a softer one and and actually to
be fair a lot of private clouds don't
have an issue with this more the issue
here is about gaining access to
corporate networks for different devices
but many organizations have sort of
moved away from this parameter based
network security model to more you know
security on the device and a lot of
organizations are being a lot more
flexible about sort of BYOD policies
working from tablet sort of thing so
this actually is improving the next big
thing in this definition of why what or
what the cloud should give you is
another biggie aware but a lot of
private clouds fall down and that says
this idea of resource pooling so this is
fundamentally a multi-talented approach
where you can pull resources across
multiple different users of the cloud
platform so here's a definition that
providers computing resources are pulled
to serve multiple consumers using a
multi-tenant 'add model with different
physical and virtual resources
dynamically assigned and
assigned according to customer demand so
quite wordy but it basically means is
you've got a whole pool of computing
resources and those things get
dynamically moved where they need to be
used as someone says I want something
you allocate the resources to that
person so they can plate access to it so
these tends to mean that to get the most
benefit out of cloud you're pooling all
of your resources together this is where
clouds will be most efficient this is
how companies like AWS and as you make a
lot of money out of the cloud because
they get to reuse resources across
different consumers I can't tell you how
many times I've gone into an
organization to find out I don't have
just one private cloud they have
multiple each division has their own
private cloud and what that basically
means is your limiting resource pooling
within those little little fiefdom that
operate within those organizations very
few organizations large-scale
enterprises that have a private cloud
actually really do resource pooling they
tend to just have limited silos here and
there what that means is you're not
getting the benefit of having the
additional computing resources at your
at your disposal
it also means you tend to have much
lower utilization because you're not
really getting the most out of the
computing resources you've got so yeah
low utilization means you've bought a
machine you know but you're only using
half of it or 20% of it and there's all
that excess capacity that's not being
used if you pull those resources you get
much more efficient usage of those
computing resources especially if you're
doing if you're having poor utilization
of your computing resources it basically
means you're spending a lot more money
than you need to
so this disappear in two ways if you're
not doing proper resource pooling it
means you have fewer computing resources
available to you when you need them but
it also means you're spending more money
on them than you need to because you've
got loads of unused capacity that you
can't make access to which is a bit
rubbish really so this is sort of
another interesting thing when it comes
to something like kubernetes because
yeah but a lot of people are now
implementing kubernetes sort of
implementing kubernetes on-premise to
give them a private Wow
and here's some is called interesting
kubernetes isn't actually designed for
multi-tenancy
and I mean that quite specifically so
kubernetes were quite happily that you
run say different services on that
saying on that saying kubernetes cluster
but it isn't designed to allow sort of
you know quite different use cases on
top of that in terms of management and
ownership of that cluster typically if
you want to have different divisions in
your organization and they want
different than a what they all want
control over part of kubernetes you end
up basically having to run federated
clusters so what that basically means is
rather than having one big kubernetes
cluster that everyone can gain access to
you end up running multiple federated
clusters to allow the different tenants
control over the different areas that
system and this is you know coming
there's this dis statement and I got
about kubernetes it's not multi-tenancy
this is might be controversial to some
this comes straight from somebody as
Alex which Alexis Richardson used to be
chair of the CNCs Technical Committee
his company does this for company you
know goes out and does it for
organisations kubernetes was never
really designed to be a full private
cloud solution and so people are having
to add a lot more stuff and layers on
top now to sort of try and make it work
within the corporate setting
so resource pooling we're not doing as
well as we could there what else we've
got rapid elasticity so here's this next
property that we're supposed to have
from our cloud computing resources so
here we go
capabilities can be rapidly inelasticity
elastically provisioned in some cases
automatically it's a quickly scale out
and rapidly released too quickly scaling
to the consumer the capabilities
available for provisioning often appear
to be unlimited and can be purchased in
any quantity at any time so basically
from your point of view when you're
working with a cloud provider you are
completely unaware of any underlying
resource constraints you basically spin
up as many machines as you need you shut
them down you don't need them so no
constraints I wonder how many people are
working with private cloud right now do
you feel like this do you feel like if
you need spin up 20 machines right now
that you could do it without even having
to ask anybody or would you have to
check in would you actually have to go
and say oh you know we allow to have
some more VMS please
because I think this is another area
where these things break down now this
rapid elasticity and that resource
pooling go hand-in-hand if you're not
pooling all the computing resources that
you've got available to you then it
limits your ability to rapidly scale
things up and rapidly scale things down
that's really gonna hurt you so rapidly
elasticity I don't know most of the
private clouds I seem don't really have
that kind of capability and next thing
is the sort of measured service this is
actually surprisingly the one area where
a lot of private clouds do quite well
because a lot of people implementing
private clouds are obsessed with cost
accounting which always seems a bit odd
to me because often I think it'd be much
more cost-effective to run these things
on the public cloud so measured service
here basically means that you could
actually work out what people have used
and charged them accordingly if needed
so I know that this team have used 25
computing resources therefore that's how
much there's going to come out of their
budget those sorts of things and this is
one area where you know that although it
has a lot of bunch of work has been done
because you've got to keep the bean
counters happy even if the technology
isn't as good as it might be when it
comes to actually using the stuff you
then get as part of this measured
service so I think so many the private
clouds that we see aren't really worth
the name because they don't actually
deliver on those five key capabilities
they fail down they fail sometimes on
they've had a lot on things like
multi-tenancy they fell a lot of
resource pooling people implement these
things and input barriers in the place
and sometimes the issue is not so much
the technology that we're using to
implement our private cloud it's
actually the processes that we put
around the use of the private cloud we
take technology which could be quite
empowering and then we hamstrung it with
arbitrary internal procedures that may
actually be based more on how we used to
do things ten twenty or thirty years ago
I saw this other interesting as bit of
research done by Gartner and I'm quite
happy to cherry-pick
reports and statistics that back up my
own internal biases and this is this is
no different there's actually research
done at a Gartner data center conference
so this is already people that were
willingly going to a garden a data
center conference right so these are
people that just probably full squarely
in the realm of traditional IT ops
management people right so they're going
this conference to talk about data
centers and basically the people the
attendees at this conference who were
you know often fairly senior level CIOs
and heads of Arts and heads of
infrastructure 95% of them said we've
got problems with our private cloud but
95% that very few of them are actually
happy with what they've actually managed
to deliver in terms of that private
cloud experience and the really
interesting thing is the biggest one of
the biggest reasons given for why the
private clouds haven't worked for them
and again this is often coming from more
traditional IT ops people is that they
were focusing on the wrong thing with
their private cloud set up they were
actually focusing way too much on cost
savings and not enough on kind of
already definers agility so they're
obsessed with the cost accounting side
of private clouds which is as I said
something that often the feature sets
are pretty good on from these private
cloud vendors but they weren't focused
on actually getting people and getting
teams to sort of use this in a way to
help them be more effective and more
efficient in delivering software they
weren't focus enough in in the speed of
movement they weren't focusing often
agility what is said is they we weren't
changing our operational models so
people are taking old-fashioned
operational models to make sense when
you're dealing with physical
infrastructure or sort of manually
virtualized infrastructure but they
weren't shifting that into the new world
all they were doing things like having
very fixed funding models so rather than
allowing teams to sort of pay on demand
people were having to say upfront 12
months in advance what their funding
models were going to be for using their
own private cloud and that's just that
is really problematic and there is
another thing really that stirs I think
often gets overlooked we obsess
sometimes on the technical capabilities
of the public cloud and all the cool
features like you know I
I'm obsessed with as your gerbil
functions I think you're amazing other
people talking about how great things
are like like bigquery and stuff on
guten tag but actually one of the most
fundamental things that public cloud has
done for us is to shift us into new ways
of working this this fundamental you
know reduction in barriers to us
provisioning the infrastructure and the
services that we need allowing a true
self-service model has fundamentally
shifted the ways of working for many
people but with private cloud it lets us
really say okay we're gonna pretend to
embrace this new technology but we're
actually going to stick it to all of our
old working practices and and this sort
of was like we we're paying the cost of
implementing these private clouds but
we're not getting any of the benefit
right you are not going to save money
with a private cloud you're gonna spend
more money in the short term and if
you're not then also gonna get the
benefit for that investment then you're
doubly damned in a way and the thing is
if you use public cloud well you can get
these promises of on-demand you get
these benefits of resource pooling yes
you can string that again if you want to
by placing buried in a place but those
organizations that use the public cloud
well they remove barriers they trust and
empower their teams
they say this is your account use it how
you see fit and that's where you get
best out of these systems
oh look there are other reasons why
public cloud is cool right aside from
the fact that it's something which gives
you this sort of read that does embrace
this idea of of some self-service
management and it and it helps shift us
into a different way of working
fundamentally the public cloud has way
more features than your private cloud
does and I say that with a high degree
of confidence so let's just take a look
at one set of features released by AWS
so hero this was just one week's worth
of features released by AWS it's
actually I took it from I think this is
this is one week in September last year
and these are all fairly major feature
announcements so these are things like
rolling out a feature to a brand new
region
sort of features brand-new products
coming out out of beta you know these
are major product announcements this is
just one week's worth of product
announcements and by the way that wasn't
happening during reinvent that was
actually a few weeks before reinvent you
can actually go to the AWS is page or if
there's new features and product
announcements and here we go just go to
aws.amazon.com slash new and you can
take a look at all the products and
announcements that were made just in
2019 alone and there were 1845 product
announcements around different features
of AWS now some Chris some people
criticize a Amazon saying it's too many
features it's too complicated there's
too much stuff maybe your that's gonna
feel like too much you to get your head
around you don't need to use all of
these products of course this is the
pace of change and when you're setting
up your private cloud and you you know
you're running your little kubernetes
cluster and thinking about regretting it
you are going to constantly be comparing
yourselves to what the public cloud
offers and they are going to outstrip
you in terms of the features and the
products offerings that they have I mean
AWS is obviously an extreme example
because this is how they work they put
lots of product out there but you are
not going to be able to deliver more
features to your developers than AWS or
Microsoft or Google are to the people
using a public cloud providers because
it's that's their job and what you're
going to be doing is playing catch-up
you're going to see your developers that
would like to take advantage of that
cloud functions why can't I do cloud
functions on my private cloud you know
and yes you're starting to see some
solutions finally deliver something like
a lambda like or cloud function like
capability on premise but they're like
in years behind what AWS and as you
already have in this regard
probably clouds also let's be honest
they're gonna have a better security
story than you are and these platforms
are secure by default you actually add
they take this stuff very very seriously
they also handle a lot of sort of the
management overhead around protecting
your their infrastructure
and they do that on a scale which you
can't even imagine right and then better
at it we are think about what happens
when you run your own private cloud
stack okay you've got the underlying
hardware that you install and manage on
top of that underlying hardware you've
got an operating system that sits on top
of that operating system you're running
some kind of hypervisor based system so
this would be something like VMware for
example of these fear this is like a
high virtualization layer that allows us
to break but unlike Hardware up into
little pieces so on top of that
hypervisor you're running then a virtual
machine operating system then maybe
you're running some kind of container
library site like docker and on top of
that you're running your container
operating system and on top of that
you're running your application isn't
that great right this is a very kind of
a standard stack if your baby be
building say containerized microservices
and I've simplified this by not putting
kubernetes into the mix and every single
one of these are layers if you're
running them your cells need management
it needs monitoring and he's patching we
even now have to patch our chips right
we're in the world where we might see
another critical vulnerability on our
Intel chips and have to patch all those
things again this is a subset of what
the stacks look like if you're running
private cloud all of this is on you how
confident are you that as an
organization you can look after or at
least like as well now if we look we
compare that with say running stuff on
the cloud let's imagine we're just doing
something like use making use of managed
virtual machines
so using ec2 on AWS for example with you
just use managed virtual machines then
those bottom three layers are already
pushed off to the underlying cloud
provider they're things that you just
don't have to worry about and no you're
now all you have to worry about are
patching your operating systems and your
containers on your application on top of
that but we can go better what about if
you go to a public cloud provider and
actually use well they contain the
platform's so using say a KS so the
manage kubernetes service on Azure for
example that's going to offload all of
this stuff here yeah I think or ECS or
eks on on AWS so using a managed
kubernetes platform a container
orchestration platform I've now given a
even ism
stuff I'm having to worry about I can
now focus my time my attention and my
energy just on my application or the
operating system running inside that
container I could go even further I
could make use of something like you
know Lander or is your cloud functions
and now all of a sudden even more of
this stack is being managed and looked
after by somebody else they are doing
these things for me you might remember a
few years ago we had this Specter and
meltdown box where you had to go in and
apply firmware fixes to all the
underlying hardware the cloud providers
did that within seven days across their
entire fleet I bet some of you are still
running on infrastructure that hasn't
yet been patched I wouldn't be at all
surprised about that
the scale of these organizations operate
at is absolutely massive
but they've built tools and technology
and expertise to be able to work with
this infrastructure at scale and so they
get this sort of these huge benefits of
working at this level they can roll
these things out incredibly quickly
because they have to be able to because
they've got so many machines to deal
with you know this is not the kind of
expertise you would expect your company
to have to have because you probably
don't need to be man to thousands of
machines and global data centers all
over the world
you're not gonna out-compete these
organizations at this stuff and nor
should you either so I just got on about
how amazing and how awesome the public
is so why doesn't everybody just go you
know what let's go use public cloud yay
let's go so why have people not all
still continuing to to embrace the
public cloud and why why have we seen
maybe this stalling in how much public
cloud is he eating into to traditional
IT infrastructure costs well I think
there are a bunch of reasons we'll go
through them now the first is we already
have computers and this is actually one
of the most common justifications that I
see for this so people already have
bought machines and they say well look
I've got machines already I want to make
use of the machines that I've got and so
we're gonna build a private cloud so why
can you change and a better way and
actually I understand this and I think
it's a rational decision because you
want to actually get some return on the
investment you've already put in however
be very careful about this as an
argument
because I've had the conversation like
this number of times why are you using a
public private cloud Bob Oh Sam that's
because we've got computers ok great Bob
why are you buying new computers well
Sam because the computers we've got are
we're approaching end-of-life so we need
to replace them Bob why are you
replacing computers because we've got a
private cloud and the private cloud
needs computers and it's this kind of
crazy conversation I'm having if you're
using a private cloud because you've got
computers that you want to make use of
and if that's the only reason you're
doing private cloud that's fine but then
don't keep buying new hardware to
replace the old hardware you've got if
you're using machines to use them
towards the end of life see your private
cloud as a temporary thing that you're
gonna move away from over time but
really question whether the machines
need to be replaced and why can't you
shift those work clothes over to the
public cloud there is this thing where
we're a bit in love with our
infrastructure once we've made a
decision - we've gone and got a budget
to sign off to buy these machines we've
had to maybe go and convince our boss
that we need them there now sitting
there we feel like this emotional
attachment our infrastructure we're in
love with our infrastructure and letting
that go can often be quite difficult
because we have an emotional involvement
with it I feel fondness towards my
infrastructure I really do
even my raspberry PI's and I think most
disposable right but we're gonna pass
this because that's not necessarily good
reason to keep using them another reason
why a lot of people say they won't use
public cloud and this is actually a
probably the most common thing the
people Satan is I don't want to be
locked in I can't use a public cloud
because I don't want to be locked in or
I can't be locked in a lock-in is a
really interesting concept so when you
dive into and he started going a bit
further and I've done some like very
informal and non scientific surveys into
this on Twitter and things and asked
people when you're worried about locking
what is it you're actually worried about
when you dive into it there's a few key
reasons to stick out one of the things
is the cloud provide is gonna learn earn
about my business and then tears this
away from me so this is a legitimate
complaint I heard specifically a
complaint that's normally aimed at
people like AWS because Amazon of zero
a retail company I don't know how true
this is to be honest with you but I
can't imagine it effects from any sector
if you sew an online e-commerce company
running your infrastructure on AWS you
might be worried about that
but I don't know how rational this one
really is the next complaint I get is
they might turn the services off so I'll
start using a cloud-based service on the
pub but better and they might turn that
service off and now I'll have to and it
will screw my business over this happens
incredibly rarely I would say no Google
on always haven't always been great at
this but AWS and Azure are very good at
maintaining services are not turning
services off I mean I think of a single
time that AWS has ever retired a service
which actually is a bit of a problem
because some of the older service
offerings they've got are actually that
good in modern eyes you look at like
simple table yeah the AWS has got they
haven't fully deprecated it it's still
there you can still use it but no one
would because everybody would rather use
DynamoDB Amazon say Tobias is first ever
products sqs was launched in 2006 it's a
very simple point to point Q there are
better queues out there available you
can still go and use it haven't turned
it off why would they turn something off
if you're using it because they're
making money so this idea that they can
attorneys services off its just never
seem to come to fruition I think there
is a concern about making use of some of
the smaller problems providers that
those companies maybe don't have the
same financial muscle as a big three
therefore might be more vulnerable to
the company itself going out of business
I think that maybe is rational but deep
worrying about these cloud services
being tariffs I've never seen it happen
from any of the big three organizations
this is another concern oh if I'm all in
on our public cloud platform the prices
might go up is that true the prices go
up on the public cloud is there's this
idea that once you're locked in I'm
doing air quotes that you can't see it
once you're locked in to a public cloud
provider then they'll start jacking the
prices up and they'll really screw you
and and people sort of say well we know
the prices are going up because AWS has
mattered to be profitable and
actually not true right there's very
little if any evidence to show any cost
increases red monk who are in my opinion
the best analyst firms out then their
stuff is really well worth reading
they've been tracking actually pricing
trends all the main providers over a
long period of time now what you can see
here is the overall trends have being
that the price has been coming down year
on year on year and over the last two
years we've seen basically a flattening
of costs so the cost of stocks reducing
but they haven't started increasing and
effectively that flattening in encaustic
basically means that you know because of
inflation that kind of means you
actually paying a little bit less for
this stuff year-on-year so there's no
trend across providers towards those
costs increasing flatlining maybe but
not increasing so there's also I've
actually also found a someone's master's
thesis which actually did analysis on
this and showed in real terms at these
club either costs are going down
although I wasn't able to really back
that up a lot of research the red monk
stuff seems be the best source of data
for this that I've found so I don't know
that this is rear a tional this worried
about costs going up that doesn't seem
to have been the case and I think when
you get down to him who start worrying
about locking it people kind of use that
term I'm gonna be stuck and and that
causes us to think I think in a negative
way about the use of these platforms or
any technology to be fair and really I
like to get people to think to think
about this this lock-in problem don't
think about being locked in think more
about the impact if you have to change
and there's actually some upside here
right so really what this comes down to
it is think about the potential
migraines so think about if I use a
cloud provider today I'm gonna benefit
today because the public cloud provider
the public cloud offering I'm gonna make
use of is likely gonna be significantly
better than what I can do myself
it just it's gonna be better so you know
the managed VMs are probably going to be
better the the s3 blobstore is gonna be
better
you're blobstore so that's going to be a
better product offering if I can use
that I can take advantage of that better
offering now but maybe later on I might
have to migrate away from it so I might
have to paid her to away from that
service if I don't lose a cloud product
today I'm avoiding the potential
migration cost later on but I'm paying
the cost now in terms of having to use a
product that's not as good for my teams
there's a really nice piece by Gregor
Hope over at Martin Fowler's website and
Gregg is talking here about sort of how
he thinks about the concept of locking
more generically and but it works really
well in the context of a public cloud as
well he sort of says well look if you've
got a service that's really really good
then actually you don't mind being
locked in because you're getting benefit
from being in that using that really
good product you accept that if they're
migrated later on it's going to be
really painful but it still might be
worth it there's kinds of locking you
want to avoid those situations where
it's hard to migrate but then they're
also terrible right so it kind of comes
up with this matrix to help you
understand that so we're looking at
unique utility so going from something
left to right so if you go further to
the right the things that are more
unique are awesome right they're great
they're things that are very hard to
find elsewhere and they're going to give
you loads of capabilities if you go from
the bottom to the top we're looking at
the switching costs so things towards
the top aren't gonna be very very hard
to move away from so something is hard
to move away from and also doesn't
really give you any unique capabilities
is something you absolutely want to
avoid and so he used it to sort of take
initial use this idea to sort of
categorize a few different things so he
says you know look at something like a
USB charger it's that it's a compatible
interface doesn't it's not really that
unique very easy to switch between him
not a worry you then compared that to
maybe the Apple ecosystem which has
loads of awesome products and features
but it's very much like a closed
ecosystem and migrating out of that is
quite painful but lots of people are
very happy being in that ecosystem an
Apple fanboy myself right because we
like being in it
as we get a great we accept that if we
have after my great he's getting to be
painful but we accept that he then looks
at something which has really this
really painful to move away from and
doesn't actually give us anything that
unique he talks about mobile phone
companies the put the services offered
by all the mobile phone companies are
pretty much the same but how many of you
have found switching your mobile phone
contracts to be a nice pleasurable
experience and I'll imagine it's not
that many of you so this idea of sort of
unique utility and that switching cost
this is kind of something that we can
you know we can actually make use of
when thinking about should I use a
public cloud provider but also going for
more fine-grained in there because it
shouldn't be just a my you using AWS or
am I going to use Azure it should be
which features on AWS or which features
on Azure am I happy to use because some
features on AWS might be things that
actually have quite a low switching cost
because it might be easy to find an
equivalent feature on a different cloud
platform other features might be harder
to find an equivalent implementation of
but might still be worth it to you
so I actually work through this we teams
I say well we look to this product or
for what you want to do let's list out
all the different product offerings that
you might be looking at use on Azure or
AWS and let's look at that cost of
migration let's look at that cost of
switching you know we look it's like
that blob storage will the benefits to
you pretty modest and actually the
migration costs of blob stores is it's
not great compute benefits are actually
quite good for you
managed VMs are quite portable so than
migration costs are quite low load
balancers yeah they're easy to replace
function as a service is really cool but
the migration costs at the moment are
quite sort of bubbling me higher it's a
lot of configuration that goes in around
the edges of these functions just
service offerings and if you look us I
like durable functions for example on
Azure there isn't really a comparable
offering on the other cloud platforms so
if you built a solution using durable
functions as awesome as they are that's
not gonna be something you could then
port to AWS without actually having to
re-implement a lot of your code this
could get even worse with some of the
databases you know things like DynamoDB
or cosmos DB don't really exist outside
of those ecosystems so if you want to
move your system that was built on say
dynamodb over to zur to work with cosmos
DB it's not just a case of moving your
much you and your configuration so also
probably going to involve changing your
code as well and that might mean that
you say well we're going to use Azure
but we're not going to make use of
cosmos DB because if we have to move
that will cost us more to migrate later
on but we will use non-durable functions
because they're portable and one of
Awesome so you can make a case-by-case
basis some assessment on these features
offerings so don't think about should I
use public clouds like a black box even
look inside that public cloud look at
the different features they offer and
some of those things are portable and
can e-book me more more easily migrated
some of those things are so unique that
you worry about the migration cost but
they're also amazing things I mean a
great example of this would be bigquery
on Google bigquery is just fantastic it
does not exist anywhere else is a way
that you can really run it but it's
awesome enough that you may actually
still want to make use of it because you
can't reproduce those capabilities
anywhere else
here's another argument I get it this is
another good one I get for why people
still have their prime bit cloud and
this one doesn't make me laugh our
private cloud is nearly good right any
day now
our private clouds going to get there
we're going to get to a good place we've
put so much time energy and investment
in it in a moment it's gonna be all
right we can see the finishing line it's
inside this is otherwise known earth
we've spent so much money in now we've
spent so much money we can't stop now
art nerds this is the heart of the sunk
cost fallacy you know if you wanna see
one of the probably most well known
examples of Z we spent so much money we
can't stop now argument look no further
than concorde in fact this thing is
called the concorde fallacy right the
Concorde project was never going to make
money all of the analysis before were in
the design stages said this thing was
never gonna break even but people wanted
to build it they started building it
they said this thing is not gonna be
financially viable it's never gonna make
money
there's also
not enough of a market for this sort of
air travel they said no it's gonna be
fine we'll build it anyway and they
built it and guess what there was no
market this did not change the world as
impressive as Concorde was as from a
feat of Engineering it never made sense
on paper it didn't make sense of reality
and actually very little of what we've
done you know the world does not fly
around in supersonic passenger jets that
just has not happened and then this is
the problem is that we we get evidence
to show us that what we're doing is
wrong but we can't change our minds
because we've already got too much
emotional investment in it and you know
we lured our politicians for not
changing their minds it seems a sign of
strength that you don't change your
decisions you know he Margaret's mother
Margaret Thatcher's most famous speeches
was this lady's not for turning I am NOT
going to change my mind basically and
this is this is daft right this is this
is idiocy
this is where we've got to though in the
face of evidence that tells us we might
not be doing the right thing we can't we
don't change our minds
because that's seen as a sign of
weakness and that's so you know
fundamentally wrong we should definitely
you know know though kind of when we get
real information from people and the
expert starts telling us something bad
we should just carry on regardless and
hope that it's all gonna be okay and
this is I think where we are we private
cloud any day now the private clouds
going to be good we'll put a bit more
time a bit more energy some new
technology will come out and it'll all
be fine
let's see where we are with this
evolution of private cloud okay so we
start off with just physical
infrastructure and that's all we had but
then Along Came virtualization and
virtualization has been massively
impactful because now we can take our
physical infrastructure and break it up
into smaller pieces and those smaller
pieces allow us to get better
utilization out of our data centers and
this has been legitimately
transformational for sort of internal
data center operations all over the
world then AWS start coming along and
saying oh maybe maybe the world looks a
bit different maybe you want a cloud
that looks a bit like this so then we
had sort of the you know the early 2000s
into the mid 2010 where an awful lot of
work went in
things like OpenStack and sir OpenStack
was a was actually originally developed
by Rackspace and NASA to actually help
run large-scale compute uh and you know
Rackspace all this opportunity to sort
of say well we can deliver an AWS like
experience on the private on a private
premise giving you a private cloud
operation and I have yet to speak to a
single Operations Manager or CIO or CTO
that says that they feel that they
they've got the benefit out of that
OpenStack implementation huge amounts of
very very smart people a lot of the
OpenStack is a piece of software as an
open source project is absolutely
amazing but fundamentally it was always
going to be struggle to deliver on the
benefits of what a cloud can be because
the software is only one part of it if
you don't change the behaviors you don't
change the skillsets
and you don't work at the same levels of
scale as the public cloud providers do
you're always gonna sort of pale by
comparison
so opens FAQ didn't really work but it's
okay because now now we've got
kubernetes so now we're all ditching
OpenStack and building kubernetes or in
the case of some of my clients they're
now putting kubernetes on top of
OpenStack which in turn of course is
sitting on top of virtualization and we
would like to think that we're getting
better right that we're slowly evolving
that step by step by step things are
improving and we're getting to a better
place
I actually think where we really are
from from a private cloud point of view
with all these new technical innovations
is that we're going from kind of one
sort of weird bacteria to slightly more
advanced form of bacteria now don't get
me wrong there are some good reasons why
you might want to use public to use a
private cloud offerings and you want
your data in country I totally
understand that I've worked with some
government agencies actually some
government agencies in Norway who are
half that's tight requirements about
making sure the data and the processing
stays in country some of those are now
looking at Azure because as you as
obviously launching in has not just in
them in Norway on-premise and in some
countries you don't have a public cloud
presence so you need to stick the local
provider by totally understand those
restrictions if that's you
some people are worried about the impact
that u.s. Patriot Act and certainly in
countries like Germany who are very
aware of privacy concerns are a lot more
sensitive to this stuff as geopolitical
elements here as well and actually the
u.s. Patriot Act is a bit of a concern
so I'll leave that to you to read into
around these sorts of things although
they're all ways to design your
applications to sidestep some of the
things that this means maybe you're
doing something incredibly specialized
the people at the Wellcome Trust to in
the UK who has sequencing genomes for
example basically by incredibly
specialized hardware to allow them to do
the kind of work they're doing I suspect
you're not doing that kind of work or
maybe you're worried about monopolies
and this is a concern right because if
we look at things with the public cloud
or vendors a very large amount of the
public cloud market is actually owned by
a very very small number of providers
some of you might have heard this term
hyper scalars so hyper scalars are those
lot those organizations operating at
massive scale that dominate the market
so that the hyper scalar companies
there's about twenty four of them I
think they now account for sixty eight
percent of all public cloud
infrastructure so it is marking and a
lot of them are running private clouds
too so that's in the hand of just twenty
four companies it's even worse when you
actually look at the other end because
really even amongst at twenty four
companies there are really four big
providers so you look at the public
cloud market share this the story is
even more stark so these this was I
think it was late 2018 data it's the big
four right
it's AWS then a big gap then it's Azure
then it's a big gap then it's Google and
Alibaba cloud pretty much neck and neck
this is gray line plummeting down which
is the rest of the market that includes
people like IBM and Oracle right and
then they are just noise on this graph
there's a reason why IBM spent so many
billions on RedHat because their cloud
strategy is not going in the right
direction and they need to boostrap this
and the problem with this is it does
mean for smaller players I mean I love
people at digitalocean that they offer
some great public cloud features that
are so-so developer friendly that the
issue is that there's so much behind the
times in a way because they can't
compete in feature set I mean
diesel ocean have only just launched for
example that late last year is the
ability for you to run your own managed
database it's something that AWS has had
since 2008 so I do worry about these
small providers in the world of these
monopolies really what I only want you
to take on board here is this idea that
I think you've got to really validate
whether or not you should be using your
own infrastructure you've got this stuff
sure but do you have to have it do you
really need a private cloud or will you
just cling onto a private cloud because
you know your source youssef can't see
another way forward there's great Oscar
by Stephen a gradient read monk said
their legions of IT staff is that will
be protecting what they believe is their
livelihood the private infrastructure at
all costs and less technical leadership
is we bring to wage total war on its own
infrastructure then private
infrastructure will continue to be a
thing people define themselves in terms
of their job and my job right now is to
look after this private machine I can't
see a future in which I'm not doing that
and therefore whether you realize it or
not
you potentially might be a barrier to to
this world changing you know if you're
an ops manager right now you're looking
after private infrastructure you have
some amazing skills that are incredibly
valuable and that private infrastructure
isn't going to vanish overnight but
those skills can be just as effective in
terms of learning to work and manage
public infrastructure and if you're you
making more use of public cloud
broadening your skill set you're gonna
find you'll be even more valuable to
your company and your colleagues give
you a good you know use no reason we
can't balance these forces so look in
summary I think that most people are
likely better off making use of a public
cloud provider and a lot of the concerns
I see around public cloud adoption I
kind of unfounded when you get down to
it car start going up services aren't
getting shut down and I think the the
thinking about lock-in is really
paralyzing us
don't let your son costs fantasy holds
you back just because you spent 10
million in the private cloud if the
private cloud hasn't worked
don't keep throwing good money after bad
and really when you're thinking about
locking which
you you were gonna adopt you can balance
your wrists by being smart make smart
decisions about which cloud offerings
you're going to use but the idea that
you're going to do nothing because you
might be locked in that's just going to
close you off and you're going to end up
being out competed by your competitors
that are more open to using some of this
stuff I've got loads more information
over at my website we've got a few
minutes left for questions I know I've
been a bit long so I do apologize for
that but I hope some of you have been
asking questions over at slider and I
just got you're gonna go take a look at
that now okay so I'm just taking your
looks we've had a question in here from
Herald which is what sorts of metrics
would you recommend use for ITIL in
regards of a cloud service as a
developer I have huge problems
explaining why I need agile services so
I'm not going to talk specifically to
ITIL because I don't know ITIL it well
enough to be able to talk the kinds of
things that ITIL practitioners care
about I do know an awful lot of what
ITIL is about is about quality of
service and all its ability and
traceability and actually one thing I
would say there is the public cloud
systems are significantly better than
your private infrastructure you can
apply tight controls to every single
cloud service you can order it what
every single person does you can have
full traceability of those things the
other thing I would say is that public
cloud offerings are all entirely
automatable they all the cloud services
have very very good API so that allows
you to write code to the automation that
code can also be version controlled and
tracked in practice when I'm working
with auditors and stuff in the past
around cloud stuff well they start
seeing what the public cloud can
actually do provide a to you they're
actually really impressed but it does
take you it doesn't mean that you have
to watch me to engage with those people
often what happens is you get your ITIL
sign off by doing certain practices and
it was such a painful process you never
actually want to change your practices
and they get so I can't speak directly
to ITIL
the other thing is I have huge problems
explaining where I need a j'l services
for me this is about that self-service
management so I would actually is a very
lit there's a very low-level thing you
can start
doing is just start tracking your time
how much time did you spend configuring
machine how long did you have to wait to
get a box and then maybe say well I
spent this month I spent 15 hours doing
nothing but managing these things are
waiting for people to do stuff for me oh
look I've clicked a button I've got a
machine on AWS
so maybe doing something like tracking
your time and tracking the wasted energy
that you have as a team across a period
of a few weeks and then doing a demo for
people internally and the thing is
you're not gonna say we're gonna move
over to public cloud overnight
necessarily but one of the things you
can start
to say okay we won't be productions
so there are ways of chipping away at
this problem okay so we are at time
thank you so much if you've got any
questions for me do go over to my you
can find my contact details at my
website or you can hit me up at Twitter
Newman
you